yes I don't know what the remarks Alex I
don't buy the Sun newspaper
you might remember port recording a
video that according to the Sun you did
on behalf of the Communist Party in
which in which you question the need for
aircraft carriers you question the need
for Britain to have a place on the
international stage in terms of Armed
Forces eg did you make remarks of that
kind of things they have to have and we
are having a strategic defence review I
do think we have to think about the
level of armed expenditure we have in
this country thirty five billion pounds
per year we are in the top five of
military spending across the whole world
I think we have to seriously look at
those issues and look at the issues of
nuclear weapons as well and also what
our foreign policy objectives actually
are and so I'm suggesting we have both
of strategic defence review and a
foreign policy review at the same time
can we afford to have global reach of a
country of 65 million people on the
northwest coast of Europe should we not
be more interested in supporting
international law working with the UN
rather than deciding that we is quite a
smug country can actually afford this
global venture now that's pretty much
I don't say that's pretty much what the
song quoted you is saying but about new
blood the son